Depending on whom you ask, bimbo can be an
insult or just a description.
Usually implying a lack of intelligence, and
often combined with physical attractiveness
and promiscuity, today bimbo is often used
to describe someone who isn’t that bright,
and gets by on her (or his) looks (or wealth).
And this meaning isn’t too far away from
the word’s origins.
The Oxford English Dictionary credits the
November issue of The American Magazine (page
69) as the first to put bimbo into print with
the line: “Nothing but the most heroic measures
will save the poor bimbo.”
Originally referring to a foolish or inconsequential
man, and in particular in a contemptuous way,
bimbo was derived from the Italian word bambino
(baby), and it retained this meaning through
the early part of the 20th century, as seen
in P.G.
Wodehouse’s Bill the Conqueror (1924) where
he referred to an entitled doofus as “the
bimbo Pyke.”
At this same time, bimbo was also applied
to women.
In 1920, Irving Berlin published a song by
Grant Clarke (words) and Walter Donaldson
(music) titled My Little Bimbo Down on the
Bamboo Isle.
Although not explicit, this use of bimbo incorporates
the connotations of attractiveness and sexual
promiscuity, as the illustrated cover of the
sheet music depicts a carefree, pretty, dancing
woman making eyes with a leering young sailor.
It was also being used to describe a voluptuous
woman in 1920, as shown in Irving Zeiman’s
The American Burlesque Show: “This Dix bimbo
is a dangerous woman . . . a sassy girl with
. . . more than a figure – a physique.”
Jack Conway of Vanity Fair is reputed to have
popularized the word with the connotation
of an unintelligent but sexually attractive
woman in the late 1920s, and by 1937, it was
being paired with blond hair, such as in Detective
Fiction Weekly’s: “We found Durken and
French LaSeur, seated at a table . . .with
a pair of blond bimboes beside them.”
Going in and out of fashion for several decades,
bimbo had a resurgence in the late 1980s,
with 1987 being dubbed “The Year of the
Bimbo” as a series of scandals that year
all prominently featured beautiful young women
right at the center of the controversies.
Although likely not a bimbo, just pretty,
Fawn Hall, secretary to the man at the heart
of the Iran-Contra Affair, Lt. Col. Oliver
North, rose to prominence when she was called
to testify to Congress over document shredding.
Tall, shapely and beautiful, with a mane of
blonde hair, while many assumed Ms. Hall was
Colonel North’s bimbo, there has never been
any evidence she was anything more than an
employee.
Not stupid, but perhaps meeting some of the
criteria of a bimbo was Donna Rice.
In 1987, popular Senator Gary Hart was the
leading contender for the Democratic nomination
for President when rumors that he was having
an extra-marital affair (a truly scandalous
accusation then) began to surface.
When questioned about them, Senator Hart actually
challenged the media to put him under surveillance,
they did, and they discovered Ms. Rice.
Blond and beautiful, Ms. Rice was observed
by two Miami Herald reporters leaving Mr.
Hart’s townhome in Washington, D.C. (presumably
Mrs. Hart was not in the nation’s capital
at the time).
Although the two denied an affair, at about
this time, a photograph of Donna Rice, showing
a lot of leg and sitting on Senator Hart’s
lap, on a yacht called (and I’m not making
this up) Monkey Business was published.
Hart’s campaign was (excuse the pun) sunk;
he withdrew from the race, Massachusetts Governor
Michael Dukakis got the nomination, and he
lost to George H.W. Bush in the 1988 election.
Donna Rice refused most media offers, including
to do an interview with Playboy, but did become
the face of No Excuses jeans for awhile.
Hands-down the bimbo-iest of the scandals
of 1987, however, was the stir created around
the PTL Club.
Short for “praise the lord,” PTL was a
hugely popular Christian television show led
by evangelists Jim and Tammy Faye Bakker.
Tammy Faye was a remarkable character with
dyed hair, a “baby-talk” voice and more
eye makeup than a roomful of Kardashians;
as such, she easily met the basic qualifications
of a bimbo.
Her husband, the preacher, Jim, was also a
bimbo but for a different reason.
Revealed in 1987, Jim and another man were
accused of drugging and raping a 21-year-old
church secretary, Jessica Hahn, in 1980.
Although the resulting scandal ruined Jim’s
career, he proclaimed his innocence of any
crime, but eventually admitted he had a consensual
sexual relationship with the young lady.
Of all the bimbos that year, Jessica Hahn
appears to have best met most of the criteria.
Well-endowed with a voluptuous figure, big
80’s hair and lots of makeup, Jessica capitalized
on her scandal by building a career centered
around her sexuality, which included posing
in Playboy, appearing in Sam Kinison’s video
for “Wild Thing” and becoming a frequent
guest on The Howard Stern Show.
Perfectly capturing the bimbos dilemma, Ms.
Hahn is quoted as saying, “people will always
consider me a cartoon character, a bimbo.
They will never give me credit,” but that
“the scandal happened and I made the best
of it.”